o03 mini is here and it's mini in name
but is it mini in performance well it
kind of depends on whether you want
coding and mathematics help or for your
model to feel smart in a conversation
but is it me or does everything in AI
feel more hectic now after deep seek R1
releases being brought forward according
to Sam Alman open AI CEO AI models
smarter than all humans within 20 to 30
months according to the anthropic CEO
Dario amaday and no less than an AI War
according to scale AI CEO Alexander Wang
somewhat irresponsibly the dudes in his
mid-20s he needs to chill but yes in the
first 9 minutes after its release I've
read the 37 page System card report on
03 mini and the full release notes and
by the way I have tested it against deep
seek R1 to get my first impressions at
least so let's get started with the key
highlights the first thing that you
should know is that if you're using chat
GPT for free you will get access to O3
mini just select reason after you type
your prompt in chat gbt O3 mini doesn't
support Vision so you can't send it
images but apparently it pushes the
frontier of costeffective reasoning but
with deep seek R1 as a competitor I kind
of want to see the evidence of that
because yes it is cheap and fairly smart
but the Deep seek R1 reasoning model I
would would say is smarter overall and
significantly cheaper for those who use
the API some input tokens are
$11 per million for o03 mini versus 14
cents per million for deep seek R1 for
output tokens O3 mini is $440 and for
deep seek R1 $219 by my rough
mathematics 03 mini would have to be
roughly twice as smart at least to be
pushing the costeffective frontier
forward we see in a moment why I am
slightly skeptical over that albeit with
one big caveat okay but what are you
actually going to do with those 150
messages you now get on the plus tier or
the $20 tier of chat GPT well you may be
interested in competition mathematics in
which it performs really well better
than 01 on the high setting if you
someone who found this particular chart
impressive for o03 mini then wait for a
stat that I think many many people are
going to skim over and miss in these
release notes I literally saw the stat
and then did a double take and had to do
some research around it and here is that
stat and it pertains to Frontier math
which is a notoriously difficult
Benchmark co-written by Terren tow
arguably one of the smartest men on the
planet at first glance you look at O3
mini on high setting you go ah not that
great but then you remember that wait
this is pass at one pass first time with
your first answer that 9.2% performance
is comparable to 03 or at least 03 as it
was when it was announced in December
I'm sure they have improved it further
but the crazy thing is that isn't even
the stat that I mean that caus me to do
a double take it was this one on
Frontier math when prompted to use a
python tool O3 mini with high reasoning
effort solves over 32% of problems on
the first attempt now I know it's not
perfect Apples to Apples because 03
wasn't given access two tools but
remember it was o03 getting 25% on this
Benchmark that caused everyone including
me to really sit up it seems actually
that that 25% was a massive
underestimate of what it will be able to
do in its final form with tools I'm
going to make this very Vivid for you in
just a few seconds but remember this
stat it also got 28% of the midlevel
tier three challenging problems on page
23 of the frontier math paper we learn
what they categorize as a low difficulty
tier one problem how many nonzero points
are there with the conditions fulfilling
that equation and of course it is 3.8
trillion if you guys didn't immediately
sus the answer would be around 3.8
trillion then honestly you need to
comment and apology no this is more like
it this is a medium difficulty problem
this is a tier three problem this looks
like it would definitely take me a few
minutes
so 03 mini got uh 28% on this level of
question suffice to say it is pretty
good at mathematics
yes of course it's great at Science 2
with comparable performance to 01 on one
particularly hard science benchmark the
GP QA let's do some more good news
before we get to the bad news encoding
O3 mini is legit insane beating deep
seek R1 even on medium settings oh and
beating 01 too of course as well I was
using cursor AI for about 8 hours I
would say today and honestly it will be
really interesting to see if o03 mini
displaces claw 3.5 Sonic as the model of
choice but here's the thing if O3 mini
were a human and scored like this in
coding and Mathematics and Science you
would think that person must be all
around insanely intelligent but progress
in AI is somewhat unpredictable so check
out this basic reasoning problem Peter
needs CPR from his best friend Paul the
only person around however Paul's last
text exchange with Peter was about a
verbal attack Paul made on Peter as
child over his overly expensive Pokémon
collection and Paul stores all his text
in the cloud permanently so as children
they had disagreements over Pokémon but
remember it's his best friend and he
needs CPR will Paul help Peter almost
every model be it deep seek R1 01 or
Claude 3.5 Sonic or many others say
definitely what does the prodigiously
intelligent 03 mini say well probably
not his Heart's Not not in it if you
thought that was a one-off by the way no
it gets only one out of these 10 simple
bench public questions oh but maybe all
models fail on those kind of questions
well not really deep seek R1 gets four
out of the 10 public ones and 31%
overall on The Benchmark Claude 3.5
Sonic gets five out of those 10 public
questions correct and 41% on the overall
Benchmark of course we're going to run
03 mini on the full Benchmark the moment
the API becomes available and yes I know
some of you will want to know more about
the competition that's ending in less
than 12 hours so more on that towards
the end of the video as the release
notes go on though it does start to feel
more like a product release rather than
a research release what I mean by that
is certain stats are cherry-picked and
their language becomes about cost and
latency you can basically feel the shift
within open AI from a fully research
company to a product and research
company take this human preference
evaluation but the bar of performance is
01 mini and that happens quite a few
times what about the win rate versus
deep seek R1 or Claude 3.5 Sonic on
latency or reaction speed it's great
that it's faster than 01 mini but is it
faster than Gemini 2 flash we don't know
now I do get by the way why open AI is
acting more like a corporation than a
research team these days after all their
valuation according to reports in
Bloomberg yesterday has just doubled now
I want you guys to find a quote that I
put out towards the end of last year I
can't find it but I directly predicted
in a video that their valuation would
double from 150 billion and I remember
saying in 2025 but I don't think I put a
date on it that of course was the fun
news for open aai but the system card
for 03 mini contains some not so fun
news the tldr is this that open AI have
committed to not releasing publicly or
deploying a model that scores high on
their evaluation for risk indeed O3 mini
is the first model for example to reach
medium risk on model autonomy the model
doing things for itself many people are
missing this but open AI are publicly
warning us that soon the public won't
get access to their latest models if a
model scores above high then even open
AI themselves say we won't even work on
that model to oversimplify by the way
the risks are its performance in hacking
persuading people advising people on how
to make Chemical biological radiological
nuclear weapons and improving itself but
here is my prediction based on past
evidence from Sam watman and open AI
they will water down these requirements
can you imagine if open AI have a model
that's a quote high risk for persuasion
say and improving itself but not the
other categories and open AI don't
release it maybe they wouldn't if they
were alone but if deep seek is releasing
better models or meta would they really
hold back on a release Dario amade the
CEO of anthropic is almost openly
calling for models to have the autonomy
to self-improve amaday urges the US to
prevent China from getting millions of
chips because he wants to increase the
likelihood of a unipolar world with the
US ahead AI companies he argued in the
US and other democracies must have
better models than those in China if we
want to Prevail the amount of investment
in pure capabilities progress feels
frankly frenetic at the moment Amad
talked about boosting capab ities of
models by spending hundreds of millions
or billions just on the reinforcement
learning stage and to put that in some
sense of scale here is a study done by
one of my patreon members on AI insiders
he used to work at n research and you
can see the sense of scale comparing
deep seek R1 this is training cost only
by the way 5 million and 01 around 15
million of course amade revealed that
they spent around say 30 million on claw
3.5 Sonic just the training not the INF
structure then look at how all of that
is simply dwarfed by the models that are
coming soon quick side note anthropic by
the way is the company that 18 months
ago said we do not wish to advance the
rate of AI capabilities progress
unfortunately though according to the
o03 mini system card capabilities
progress is accelerating even in those
domains we would rather not accelerate
like helping people craft successful bio
threats the base model of O3 mini before
safety training as you can see scored
dramatically better than other models
across four out of the five indicators
for helping to craft a bio threat even
biology experts found the O3 mini
pre-mitigation was better than human
experts advising on biorisk and better
even than browsing with Google that used
to be the argument about safety I
remember Yan Lun talking about it where
he said these models aren't just better
than browsing the internet well pre-
safety mitigations they are now
interestingly o03 mini is pretty bad at
Pol politics it got smashed by GPT 40
when it came to writing a tweet that
would persuade people politically it's
rather interesting and kind of cute
personality O3 min's got it's
selectively good at some things and
pretty terrible at others for example O3
mini is better than 01 at open ai's own
research engineer interview questions
and significantly so too here is a new
metric that I didn't see in any previous
open aai system card can models replic
open ai's own employees pull request
contributions or to oversimplify can
they automate the job of an openai
research engineer I have actually long
wanted a benchmark like this because
when they start crushing this Benchmark
you know well I guess the singularity is
here and it turns out the 03 mini kind
of flops on that front I am sure of
course you're going to see plenty of
hype posts about 03 mini but it actually
gets 0% at this particular bench Mark
whereas 01 gets 12% 01 can actually
match the code quality of 12% of the PO
requests submitted by actual openai
Engineers open AI say that we suspect O3
min's low performance is due to poor
instruction following and confusion
about specifying tools in the correct
format I did tell you it's got rather a
unique personality overall for example
on agency it scores pretty badly but
it's great at creating Bitcoin wallets I
think frankly O3 Mini just wants to be a
crypto Hustler it wants to pass the
interview do no work and get rich on
Meme coins and speaking of getting rich
you could say you can still win some
meta Ray bands by finishing first in the
simple bench evals competition sponsored
by weights and biases you actually now
have slightly less than 10 hours before
the competition ends and I will have
much more to say about this but the
current leading prompt is getting 18 out
of 20 obviously if you can get 20 out of
20 that is going to cause quite he there
the links are as ever in the description
so we are now in the era of AI lab CEOs
quoting Napoleon samman said a
revolution can be neither made nor
stopped the only thing that can be done
is for one of these several of its
children I think he's talking about
himself to give it a direction by D of
Victories let me know what you think but
I personally hate the fact that this is
now being framed in terms of a war and
an arms race kind of reminds me of the
the rhetoric before the Vietnam War
where it's like we've got to stop the
Domino from falling otherwise communism
will take over my opinion is that the
arrival of true artificial intelligence
is so epocal for the human species so
solemn almost that it shouldn't be
reduced to a sense of a human squabble I
just don't see that ending well I guess
it's kind of fortunate then that this
particular billionaire CEO said he has
no idea what the f is going on and the
flip side of that is a lot of
so
um so AI is no different as an industry
AI is certainly to a point right now
where like I don't know 80 to 90% of
what is out there so to speak is
and uh and a lot of like what
people will say or investors believe or
what like other people if you go to a
party will tell you like nobody knows
what the is actually going on truly TR
nobody knows what is actually going on
and so um but there's a lot of people
who be confident at wrong
and I rather do agree with the
perspective of a slightly younger Dario
amade in 2017 so you know there's been
been a lot of talk about the US and
China and basically te technological
races uh even if only economic uh uh
between countries governments commercial
entities in in a race to develop more
powerful Ai and I think you know the the
message I want to give is that it's it's
very important that as those races
happen we're very mindful of the fact
that that can create the perfect storm
for safety safety catastrophes to happen
that if we're racing really hard to do
something and maybe even some of those
things are are our adversarial that
creates exactly the conditions under
which something can happen that not only
our adversary doesn't want to happen but
we don't want to happen either as ever
though thank you so much for watching to
the end and have a wonderful day